we were wondering this Steve Garvey is
joining us on behalf of a King's
Hawaiian do tell you about their
ballpark grills at Yankee and Dodgers
stadiums and actually we love that Kings
products we've we've had those before
their friend of the show so Twitter
handle is at King's Hawaiian as a Steve
Garvey joins us now we were wondering
this I think 10 time all-star is that
right Steve won them all how many you
want all 10 all-star game record yeah
how many 10 time all-stars are not in
the Hall of Fame aside from you it's but
do you think you should be in yeah you
do I do
why aren't you I have to ask you that
and I have to ask the guys that because
every time I go in the ballot now it's
it's been modified to 16 voters and if
but you got to do your homework you got
to look at my whole career and body of
work yes
and when you do you say well every time
I go on a show oh you should be the Hall
of Fame and it just takes the voters to
do it so you look at the consecutive
game streak nationally record fourth
all-time 200 seasons 5 World Series 10
all-star games and MVPs and NLCS and
season and you know please help me add
it up I don't think that very few guys
that have a comparable palliative of a
career yeah that's what we were
wondering though a 10 time all-star MVP
in the all-star game a couple of times
several times is that right and then
Gold Glove winner a few times one of
those for those to mix in you know
Paulie what kind of postseason stands DF
for Steve they're actually better than
his regular season stats he's a 338
career postseason hitter with 11 home
runs MVP and 84 the NLCS MVP and 78 of
æneas and I'll see us we all think Hall
of Fame thank you yeah we could Lobby
though for you you know yes 14 but
there's certain names that just resonate
you hear someone's name or growing up
you get their baseball card and you get
that extra excitement I got the Steve
Garvey car and it's like it's just it's
beyond me how it's like not a no brainer
that by now they wouldn't be part of
that group and cookie you know I get a
chance to speak 40 or 50 times they
truly love it motivational speeches and
so forth and half the time I'm in
and and you want to correct him but you
go and just just let it go for now you
know and it has a nice ring to it and
maybe some day but that's every time I
do a show the same question comes up
then next year on the ballot again and
God willing but do you think is the
voting system correct and how we
approach this I know that you might be
biased and say no it's not but are we
approaching hall-of-fame voting
correctly in your opinion well it's from
the evolution of all the Hall of Famers
voting and there was a Veterans
Committee and then they modified it and
now they it's it 16 voters
so when you say Lobby you really have to
Lobby who the final 16 are and it's
probably four members of the press and
media and for front office and four or
five Hall of Fame players and then it's
subjective from there but you know like
we talked about before you really have
to look at all the things that that
compiled my career and then it's a
pretty unique one so Steve Garvey
joining us here a best player you played
against was who are Pete Rose no
question well there's always a question
I mean everybody has you know things
they factor in but day in and day out
competitor if you were to have a son or
daughter and you wanted him to look at
one player as to how they played the
game you would point to Pete should he
be in the Hall of Fame
you should nope no question and no
problem with the wine okay
well I think that you know in this this
country and Pete made a mistake and and
he said I think an addiction to gambling
and he was subjectively caught and he
was suspended and banned for life and he
also paid his dues to society you know
he did his time
whether it was a halfway house or jail
or whatever it is and in restitution and
then I think we shouldn't go back into
society and get a chance again and if
you're talking about gambling now you
know and we're talking about opening the
gates then you should look back and say
and that was the one rule when you
walked into the to the clubhouse was
gambling rule and now it's the other
billboards have been added but she
should look back and at least give him a
chance to be on the ballot in the future
did you ever hear of anybody else with
gambling in baseball nothing that denied
and then I was pretty focused I mean I
had my locker room and and and my locker
and I rarely knew if anybody was taking
drugs or or if they would be gambling
because I was so focused on 162 games
and the playoffs and getting ready and
doing my job as a everyday player and
later that I didn't look for it but you
had steroids in football back in the 70s
right but did like it wasn't prevalent
it didn't feel like it was prevalent in
a major league baseball not until late
80s why is it that did we think that it
might not help your swing or it wouldn't
help a pitcher well they used to tell us
and and the Dodgers you know we're
always in the forefront of these things
I mean I actually talked him into the
first Nautilus equipment back in the in
the 70s I mean we broke the ice with the
knowledge machine right because
everything else was like free weights
and the old term was used baseball
equipment to get in baseball shape so
that was their philosophy you don't want
to be too bulky you wouldn't be you know
lean and flexible and so forth and then
the evolution really of weight training
and I and I was a football player in a
Michigan State we trained and I always
thought if you and I are comparable as
athletes but I'm stronger I'm gonna be a
better performer and in the long run so
with the evolution of the business of
sports and the business of the game you
are always gonna have participants find
ways to cheat you talked about football
at Michigan State and then I started to
do some research here and that Michigan
State team that you were on the 1960 18
66 67 freshmen that's 67
okay so they were up against Notre Dame
that's the game of the century and ended
up 1010 Todd Duffee Doherty was Michigan
State's head coach era Parseghian
coaching at Notre Dame you went to
Michigan State did you go there to play
baseball or football well I was
originally contact for baseball and then
they found out that I was pretty good
quarterback at a
tamperer Chamberlain high school so I
did my visit I had about 20 offers I had
Harbor in Florida State Miami
you know one for each one though they
were starting to specialize so my
pitching goats in high school had played
for Danny litweiler who was the baseball
coach at MSU but had been at Florida
State so I go from any trip I go into
the the old Jennison Fieldhouse with the
trophies and he's showing him all of a
sudden this leprechaun of a man comes
around the corner and it's stuffy door
to the old Irishman and it's charming
and Stevie calm eases where did you
fight a little football son I said I do
he says you know here at Michigan State
you can play both and you know we got
23,000 coeds I guarantee we're gonna get
a date he's charming that wasn't doing
bad at the time but I think I love the
yard and so I came out and I had again
played top level high school football in
Florida and became all of a sudden I was
quarterback in first week and then they
lost a couple defensive backs and and
deaf he says Darby ever played defense
they said think you have son having a
citizen level right corners afternoon
it's a dummy me and it intercepted a
pass and made some tackles did
quarterback knowledge you know and after
the skirmish II said split your time so
within a week I was back to being a
corner vacuum and that was hit for being
quarterback but I got a chance to play
and we do were just talking about it
they played against any notable players
and about the third or fourth week
fourth week and 67 USC came to East
Lansing and and to give you a scouting
report each guy gets about a paragraph
and I'm looking at potential receivers
and backs and I Steve this guy with
initials out of San Francisco City
College by name is Simpson I mean he had
he had three paragraphs
and they put at the end by the way they
have an Olympic track team and instead
of lining up four and four in every play
I lined up for in about twelve because
they weren't gonna beat me so that day
had four or five tackles against him but
people say anything memorable I said
first quarter first and two on on our
goal and of course you don't line up in
the end zone didn't past past much it at
that time so they pitched the ball to OJ
and I'm there at the goal line and I'm
ready for him and I spear them and great
tackle he drags me in the end zone and
picks me up nice tackle and when I'm
speaking I say you know It was as if I
got hit by a white Bronco
how could Garvey say something you might
get in the Hall of Fame now I'm going
for a broad base of constituents but I
do tell my sons working here in Congress
now for Rodney Davis had a villa noise
so he's the one that's that's getting
did you think of being a politician at
one time yeah I was I was a Reagan
Republican and I used to introduce the
President as campaign stops out west and
knew Nancy pretty well and that was back
in 82 88 it was it was pretty neat time
how many celebrities would come out to
Dodger games who were the were the big
celebrities well we had the greatest
celebrity you know Sinatra Oh Sinatra
would come out and Martin and Jerry
Lewis and I mean it was it was a who's
who and they would have fun and we would
have fun with them and did you go to
Sinatra's house I had been there yeah
yeah what was that like yeah it's like a
temple you know so to speak very a
compound and anybody who it was always
very nice a great baseball fan yeah and
any promise Lasorda that he would sing
the national anthem it was sort of
became manager of the Dodgers
so 1977 opening day and they give Frank
a Dodger jacket
had he puts it on that jaunty style and
he goes to centerfield and it's was
sorta and myself and Burt Hooten and
we're all standing there with our hats
over our hearts and Frank starts out and
as the woman melting and forgot they
think the third stands it was a shortest
national anthem in the history of Major
League Baseball and in Burt Hooton is
dry humor says heck is that guy and we
sorta says I'm skipping to your starts
it was funny it was a different time I
mean we'd go into Chicago and Tom had a
lot of friends there and of course Jilly
had his his spot there and you know 70s
80s it was fun you had a good seat for a
Reggie Jackson when he hit three home I
did I did I've had a great seat in the
house for a lot of things what's the
most memorable moment you've had whether
you're you know in the field yeah yeah
Hank Aaron's 715 I was there that I
didn't did you congratulate Hank when he
got to first well it's it's those
moments I'm watching there's a pretty
high ball to left field and I'm watching
and watching I see a go over and I see
Bill Buckner my dear friend climbing the
fence and unfortunately Tom House had
beat him there and I turn around and
he's just going by and I thought shoot
you know I I didn't rethink this road
job would you have congratulated him
absolutely and Billy Russell and Davey
Lopes at second base and they did and
then of course see him from his two fans
chasing them and so forth and then you
fast forward to Reggie and he it's his
third home run at Yankee Stadium and I
watch him and Reggie's got that little
bit of a job well he leaves and that'll
lead right they don't have any home runs
you know I believe
and back then you got around the bases
quick because the picture is how in the
heck could that guy at home run so he
looks at me and I'm clapping my glove a
little bit and he winks and he goes by
and of course we lose and you know 2530
minutes afterwards pretty quiet and then
dick young a great writer column New
York New York daily comes and he says
are you clapping in your glove yeah and
he said I've never seen that before and
I said well there are times in your
profession we've got to recognize
greatness and that was a great
performance and I said I just wanted him
to know that that I recognized it I
understood so fast forward to 1981 and
now it's the bottom of the ninth we got
a four run lead and if you look at the
replays Reggie's at first and he's
talking to me and what he's saying is
garbage your turn now they said thanks
and he patted me on the behind next
pitch to Valders to kenny'll and row and
centerfield and it's the culmination
it's that and it almost freezes because
all the days you're playing in the
backyard and you're playing wiffle ball
cork ball or I used to hit little
grapefruits by myself with you know
broomstick and for me it was always
Yankees Dodgers and Dodgers won most the
time but finally you win a World
Championship for real yeah and what do
you do you run the pictures man so I run
Yeager gets Steve Yeager gets to Steve
Hal picks him up and I come flying in
the highest I've ever lived before it's
a great Sports Illustrated picture now
the next thing most people don't know is
we come down he spins how how clocks me
there's elbow gonna chill my hat falls
down and if they didn't have this Irish
chin I think of this I would have been
out cold on the pitcher's mound at
Yankee Stadium and the highlight of my
career
yeah well my parents have been from New
York and you know the old if you break
down on the Long Island Expressway or
something come back 15 minutes that car
stripped gone only a friend I
immediately think I got to pick up my
hat here and get out of here but if I
was not cold can you see me pair of
sanitary boxers and that's it
and yank you save you by the way you
know what you hit med series for some
417 yeah those see we we it feels like
we helped or we look at a picture and
say what they do in the postseason not
as much as we do a hitter um and I'm not
sure if maybe we look at pitching being
more valuable in the World Series of the
playoffs and those pitchers stand out
whereas you know yeah why aren't we why
aren't we shining the spotlight on
hitters as well and and when I speak now
I talked about remember when Mother's
used to want their sons to be doctors
and lawyers well now they want him to be
pitchers think about you work once a
week eight 150 hundred sixty million
dollars yeah concave chest little
handicap they take the clubs on the road
right I mean and that's poor guys who go
out everyday 162 games and hot weather
and humidity and so forth so well did
you ever have a bad relationship with a
pitcher
no no buddy I tell you what had anybody
within now a fight sir right sure
ridiculous you never went to the mound
no everyone I think what happens dogpile
you end up with dislocated shoulders and
wrists and elbows and hands normally I
would find my comparable guy on the
other team like the last day of 1984 we
had we had three fights at Fulton County
Stadium between the Padres and the
Braves and after the first one that that
was a little you know a little pushy
little ballet type of stuff yeah and the
next one starts and I look at Dale
Murphy he looks at me we go grab each
other and we dance over the side we do
the two-step over the side and we're
looking at him go this guy is really
crazy out there so fight the problem is
we can't hit Pascal Perez who hit down
and Wiggins on the first pitch of the
game remember this so we have first
picture can't do it second pitch you can
do it now seven guys are thrown out
because of you know that fights ensuing
so finally bringing in Craig Lefferts
and he finally hits Pascrell Perez so I
know what's gonna happen so I run out to
the man you can see I run out and I'm
like this my old defensive back stance
my arms out and it's like the parting of
the Red Sea these guys come and they go
around
and I'm there like this right I'm gonna
sacrifice my body for my picture and I
look around and love for love riches is
sprinting towards the bullpen in left
field see your left by yourself it
wouldn't be a picture yeah
who do you get mistaken for um oh gosh
Pierce Brosnan's yeah I could see that
uh are you Superman you know remember
the Christopher Reeve yeah that's
sometimes nice I tell these guys the
story I was working at CNN and I was
gonna do an interview with you at Shea
Stadium and Shea Stadium was horrible to
do interviews because the planes kept
going over him from you know but you
said hold on you just got done with BP
and you go hold on and then you went
into the locker room came out your hat
was off your hair you had to go in and
comb your hair really yeah I mean your
hair looked perfect you tell many people
this I did I told my audience yeah yeah
well I had done it Vitalis commerciai
was my first commercial yeah you know
but you did you went in and combed your
hair and and representing the national
pastime you took your hat off and you
were a young kid I gotta make you look
good no no you made me look yeah you can
make a career out of this eight or nine
different outlets right now or well no I
don't know we're we're somewhere we're
we're gonna yeah we're hey what you're
gonna get to King's Hawaiian now well we
love at the house yeah we love Kingston
one you know the buns are great there
yeah absolutely so what all ballplayers
do they go into marketing and media
consulting and I've got a few clients my
advanced age and you got Dodger Stadium
in Yankee Stadium forever okay we create
the King swine girls which we use the
rolls and we do tri-tip and pulled pork
and and we've been a little sacrilegious
we put barbecue pulled pork on on Dodger
dogs which is a smash hit right oh
really
and we do wings and we've created this
epicenter of food and now you know it's
a small 30 franchise fraternity and they
hurt wait a minute Barbies got this
place is doing great this King's
Hawaiian Grill Dodger Stadium Yankees
called us going great in Yankee Stadium
finding a new spot that they're
expanding at Fenway and we're
negotiating with with Wrigley so well
know Wow by the time next season comes
I'm pretty sure we'll be in the four
iconic stadiums and maybe you'll be in
the Hall of Fame dad growing voting's
next year yeah how many more years you
have on the ballot this this expansion
area you could probably keep going until
oh there's not a certain number that you
15 on the initial ballot okay yeah yeah
and then after that you rotate to the
the different eras now which I think you
know I give the Hall of Fame credit
there they're trying to expand the
opportunities for players that may have
gotten lost in the big numbers you know
three thousands and things like that
there are so many very good players and
I know I could rattle off a bunch of
them right now that could easily match
guys in the Hall of Fame now but if you
and the guys in the whole thing deserve
to be in there it's like anything but I
think the Hall of Fame needs to to
expand and maybe even make a couple of
determinations on them maybe pick a
player to each year that has really made
a difference in the game of baseball I
mean I was a batboy in Spring Training
in 1956 for the Brooklyn Dodgers my dad
was a Greyhound bus driver came home the
night before and said you want to skip
school tomorrow and I said yeah what are
we doing so well I've got a charter to
pick up the Brooklyn Dodgers tomorrow
take him to st. Pete to play the Yankees
an exhibition game and he said I think
it might be a fun day for you and I and
the next day Here I am batboy in for the
Dodgers it was Jackie Robinson's last
spring you know boy and Hodges and Reese
are talking about the Yankee pitcher and
how he's holding the ball for a breaking
ball on a fastball and not wasting time
not talking about where they're going to
dinner you know tonight but just in case
six months from then they're facing this
pitcher in the World Series
and he does this it'll be a breaking
ball and if he does this will be a fast
ball and I my dad and two other
gentlemen
just started the second Little League in
Tampa and I was gonna have my first game
and I really didn't know what they were
talking about but I knew I'd picked up
enough to realize they were waiting and
learning in that wasting time Robinson
sat on my lap didn't see me and
literally sat on my lap
and Monday show-and-tell this is going
to be the best story they're gonna hear
first grade at Louis elementary school
but that day that night I went home and
mom had dinner and I was an only child
at seven kids now God's family and she
said I was your day and I kept talking
for 35 minutes and went to bed and
couldn't go to sleep and kept smelling
something and my dad came in he said I
thought you were tired iced yeah but Dad
I can't go to sleep that comes over any
sniffs he says you know that rag on the
on deck circle it's at the edge that was
pine tar you got pine tar in your hand
why she can't hit it up again and he and
then he looked at me as parents do to
their children he said you know you you
probably never forget that smell the
rest of your life and and I have it to
this day I've been blessed to be part of
the national pastime and and to be able
to do interviews and promote it and talk
about it with you guys and do a few
other things too but but that's why this
game is so special we've got to be
really careful we don't alter it too
much I think that we should come out
with pine tar Cologne what do you think
Steve's the RV's pine tar my middle
names Patrick's Steve Patrick Garvey
Kyle get pine 51% they'll get 49 ah it's
good it's gonna be a summer fragrance
because I appreciate you coming in want
everybody to try our King swine grills
and you're gonna be getting some
sampling and the website is King's
Hawaiian dot-com Twitter is at King's
Hawaiian the great Steve Garvey we're
back after this in the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]